lorsque l'on parcourt les stands du
salon des arts ménagers
la première chose qui frappe c'est le
nombre d'objets qui sont fabriqués en
matière plastique
depuis quelques temps on assisté à une
véritable invasion
à telle enseigne que nos grands mères
lorsqu'elle se promène dans une boutique
10 mais qu'est ce qu'on ne fait pas en
matière plastique
oui qu'est-ce qu'on ne fait pas en
plastique le plastique est partout avec
du plastique ont fait tous le faire
disparaît peu à peu car on avait des
ennuis avec la corrosion
le plastique le supplante
ceci ce n'est pas du plastique
c'est du bois matériau traditionnel par
excellence que l'on a utilisé pendant de
très nombreuses générations seulement
n'oublions pas qu'on a utilisé le bois
parce qu'on n'avait pas autre chose sous
la main
l'avènement du fer a marqué un progrès
pour l'humanité on avait un matériau
beaucoup plus rigide et peu à peu il a
supplanté le bois on peut dire que notre
civilisation technique est bâti sur le
faire seulement il existe un autre
matériau qui lui aussi a supplanté un
peu le faire dans certains domaines ce
fut le vert le vert est aussi un
matériau traditionnel seulement ils
présentent un énorme inconvénient sa
mise en oeuvre
ces procédés d'élaboration son long
fastidieux fer vert bois voilà une
trilogie sur laquelle a été bâti toute
notre civilisation
seulement la technologie permet
maintenant de fabriquer de nouveaux
matériaux
si l'on mettait le temps du plastique en
musique vas-y vas-y qu'on y perdrait son
temps de temps en temps en y gagnant des
souhaits des piges des bijoux en
plastique il ya plus économique amie
camille bien plus intéressant or et
diamants que l'on parque longuement en
gare de foix c'est bien plus fantastique
que ti tactique on y voit le prat en
face sombre affaire d affaires d faire
un papier
oui en effet qu'est ce que le plastique
monsieur léger vous qui êtes ingénieur
chimiste dans cette usine de matières
plastiques pour vous qu'est ce que c'est
que le plastique
je vois qu'ils allaient nécessaire de
définir cette herbe plastique pour bien
pour la ménagère on appelle le plastique
en somme tout ce qui n'est pas fait avec
des matériaux traditionnels comme le fer
le bois ou le vert oui merveilleuse le
thème classique et après jour at il dû à
une période la période
pénurie des matières premières ou ces
matières de ces matériaux traditionnels
ont été remplacés par les plastiques
mais depuis ces matières plastiques ont
évolué ont obtenu monde atteint des
performances techniques et
technologiques terre qu'à l'heure
actuelle elles sont utilisées le thé
sont de plus en plus utilisé dans toutes
les industries
à tel point que l'on peut admettre à
l'heure actuelle que d'ici la fin
d'année le volume de production les
matières plastiques de l'industrie des
matières plastiques sera égale sinon
supérieure à celle à studio bon alors le
plastique c'est avant tout un matériau
le plastique est un matériau un matériau
est artificiel créé et fabriqué par
l'onu oui le plastique est un matériau
artificiel c'est du synthétique comme
l'on dit mais pour le fabriquer il faut
bien partir de quelque chose donc les
matières plastiques sont des substances
artificielles
mais pour les fabriquer vous parti vient
de quelque chose le partant de
deux balles
liquides ou gazeux qui sont des dérivés
du charbon ou du pétrole est de plus en
plus
quand l'or ici dans cette usine de
fabrication de matières plastiques que
quel est votre point de départ vient
nous utilisons un produit de base le
styrène produits liquides durée de l'eau
seulement et de ce produit liquide
nous obtenons en définitive ce produit
et c'est ça la matière plastique c'est
ceci la matière plastique et où se fait
le passage donc de ce liquide à la
matière plastique qui est solide nous
introduisons dans cet appareil le
produit liquide dans le haut de cet
appareil et par une succession de
transformation chimique
nous obtenons le produit solide la
police grecque
comment se fait cette transformation et
bien simplement parce que les chimistes
appelle une polymérisation
cela consiste tout simplement à
accrocher des molécules les unes aux
autres
un peu à la manière des wagons pour
faire un train on obtient alors une
poudre une poudre blanche pour des
raisons esthétiques on va la colorée on
va donc la mélanger à des colorants la
réchauffer pour obtenir ce boudin qui
sort de la machine
le boudin passe dans une filière pour
obtenir de long macaronis coloré qui
vont être haché menu menu pour faire des
granulés ça sera ça la matière plastique
tels que l'on pourra l'utiliser
non
voilà la matière première empaqueté dans
des containers là se termine le travail
du fabricant en quelque sorte maintenant
après expédition on le retrouve chez un
utilisateur c'est à dire un
transformateur la matière se présente
donc sous ces granulés qui vont être
aspiré un peu à la manière des grains de
blé dans un silo avant de subir la phase
de transformation
les grains de matières plastiques sont
réchauffés dans la machine que nous
voyons on leur donne une consistance
d'une pâte molle qu'un piston pousse
dans un moule de façon à obtenir
directement la pièce fabriquée
comme vous le voyez le procédé est
simple rapide et efficace en moins de 30
secondes à partir de granulés de
matières premières on obtient un objet
fini prête à l'emploi ici serait
intéressant d'établir un parallèle avec
les matériaux traditionnels comme
l'acier en effet à partir du minerai de
fer
on obtient par à l'aide du haut fourneau
l'acier cet acier doit être cool et puis
la pièce après des moulages doit être
ébarber subir après d usinage alors
qu'ici rien de tout cela on obtient un
produit fini un produit prêtes à
l'emploi
voilà mes nageurs comment naissent vos
ustensiles ménagers que ça soit un
casque le séchoir ou bien un robot pour
faire la cuisine
ce ne sont que des pièces de plastique
assemblée mais c'est du véritable
plastique c'est un matériau noble qui
doit tenir sa place dans votre panoplie
oh